calling all Potterheads
upside down magic will totally remind
you of so many aspects of the magical
movies you love we've discovered 10 ways
the Disney Channel original movie will
have you doing a double-take with Harry
Potter but we've also found five
important ways it's different we're
confident that upside-down magic will
satisfy our need to see magical
friendships and witchy powers on our
screens once more but while we wait for
the DCO em to premiere on July 31st
let's break down just how similar it is
to Harry Potter and the ways it's
totally original to you know we're here
upside-down magic takes place at sage
Academy for magical studies the majority
of Harry Potter takes place at Hogwarts
School for Witchcraft and Wizardry
they're both boarding schools for
magical kids where they take lessons in
different magical subjects upside-down
magic follows nori and her best friend
Rina as they start their studies at sage
Academy it's run by headmaster night
slinger who calls it the world's
greatest magic school in the trailer we
see the main hall at Sage which has
exposed wooden beams and rafters like
Hogwarts
there are lanterns hanging down from the
ceiling which remind us of the floating
candles in the Great Hall at Hogwarts
and that's not the only similarity
between the school set up hmm
depakote very difficult one of the most
famous things about Hogwarts is the four
houses Gryffindor Hufflepuff Slytherin
and ravenclaw the sorting hat decides
which house to sort each of the new
students into each year based on their
qualities there are houses or schools at
sage Academy too but at the magical
school in upside-down magic there are
five houses not four in the book series
they're called the five FS of magic
fuzzies flickers fliers flares and
flexers fuzzies can't communicate with
animals flickers can turn invisible or
turn other things invisible those
talented in flying are fliers those who
work with fire and heat are flares and
fluxes can turn themselves into animals
like a little bit of llama the witches
and wizards and upside down magic that
can turn themselves into animals remind
us of the animagus characters in Harry
Potter and animagus as a witch or wizard
who can transform into an animal and
back again at will
Professor McGonagall could turn into a
cat Harry's dad James could turn into a
stag sirius black becomes a black dog
Peter Pettigrew became a rat and Rita
Skeeter could turn into a beetle an
upside down magic this ability to
transform into an animal is a key point
Nori's wonky magic makes her turn into
ad written half dragon half kitten we
see this in the teaser and in the main
trailer and it's that in ability to
transform into just one animal but lands
her in the upside Dale magic last known
as the UDM let's see you do it upside
down magic nori is part of the UDM group
the upside down magic class their
teachers description of them is that
their walkie they're weird and their
magic is defective these kids are
treated differently they're sent away
from the main school building and not
allowed to do magic but nori is
determined to prove that you DMS can be
taught and do magic the right way
although it's not a total replication of
the discrimination in Harry Potter there
are definite similarities with the way
half-blood and muggle-born wizards and
witches like Hermione Granger are viewed
by pure Bloods like Draco Malfoy no one
asked your opinion there isn't any
difference in their magical ability in
Harry Potter but they're treated like
they're less worthy particularly when
they're called mudblood
the highly offensive insult clearly it's
full of dark magic the head teacher at
sage Academy says that the UDM is upside
down magic is the perfect host for
shadow magic this is the dark force that
is feared in their magical world and
nori and her friends are determined to
overcome it the head teacher says you
DMS are shadow magic soul target as long
as they don't practice magic their magic
will die she says they need to keep them
hidden away to protect humanity in Harry
Potter the main characters are fighting
a dark force too in their case the Dark
Lord Himself Voldemort and his Death
Eaters
page 49 Harry Potter started life as a
series of seven books by JK Rowling
upside down magic is also based on books
specifically the New York Times
best-selling children's book of the same
name by Sarah malinovski Lauren Myracle
and Emily Jenkins and guess what there
are seven books in that series too
they're called upside down magic sticks
and stones showing off dragon overnight
whether or not the big shrink and hide
and seek there are differences between
the upside down book and the movie
interestingly the movie has added a new
major character keep watching to
discover why that's a big deal Daniel
Radcliffe wasn't a famous child actor
when he starred as Harry Potter he only
had a couple of small credits to his
name the Harry Potter films were Rupert
Grint and Emma Watson's first big acting
jobs - and Disney has also gone down the
same route of casting and unknown in the
main role for upside-down magic Isabella
Rose of stars as nori this is her first
big acting gig Sienna a Guo dong stars
as her best friend Rina Sienna has a few
credits to her name most recently the
Netflix original series no good Nick
we're immediately reminded of Hermione
from Harry Potter when we hear that Rina
is top of her class in upside Dale magic
she's an honor student in the flare
school that's the school for witches and
wizards that have fire magic Rena
clearly has a talent for working with
flames and heat Hermione was top of her
classes too and was known as being a
know-it-all but what about nori
well Nora's at the other end of the
scale with her wonky magic her academic
struggles in the UDM class remind us of
harry and ron who struggled to keep up
with their lessons at hogwarts you don't
want to go making friends with the wrong
sort Harry Ron and Hermione friendship
is at the heart of Harry Potter but the
BFFs aren't without their issues and an
upside-down magic we're given a complex
friendship to this time it's between two
friends rather than three Disney said
that at the heart of our story is nori
and Riina's friendship in which they
help each other learn that what makes
them different makes them special we can
already see that Rena and orey's
friendship is going to be put to the
test in the trailer we hear Rena being
warned that nori is her best opportunity
to fall even further behind Snape is one
of the teachers protecting the stone
it's not a baby to steal it if we were
to say to you that there's a
groundskeeper that's also a teacher and
he leads classes from his Hut in the
woods who would spring to mind
Hagrid of course but we're not talking
about Harry Potter we're talking about
upside down magic specifically the
groundskeeper and professor buds Griff
who's played by Kyle Howard he's the UDM
teacher it definitely looks like nori
and the rest of the you DMS are
considered misfits by the rest of the
school and Harry Ron and Hermione could
be considered misfits too they don't tow
the line or fit in as their two
interesting unique and different to
blend into the background Hagrid is also
a misfit having been expelled from
Hogwarts so that's ten ways that
upside-down magic is similar to Harry
Potter welcome to the night bus
emergency trauma spoke for the stranded
witch overs it one of the major
differences between the two movies is
that Harry Potter is set in Britain with
a British cast whereas upside-down magic
is North American although both are set
in magical woods they're still very much
anchored in their real-world locations
and that's a big difference
Diagon Alley and Harry Potter is like an
image of old-fashioned London in
Victorian times Hogwarts is an ancient
castle sage Academy on the other hand is
more modern it's interesting to compare
both of them to the castle style school
of auradon prep in The Descendants
movies which school would you most like
to attend out of those three one of the
major features of Harry Potter is the
difference between the magical world and
the muggle world harry didn't even know
he was a wizard until he got his
invitation to Hogwarts or that a magical
world even existed it seems like an
upside-down magic however there's no
tension between a magical world and a
non magical world in the teaser trailer
Nori's home looks like a regular house
on a regular street but her dad calls up
to her about packing for magic school as
if it's no big deal and nothing out of
the ordinary I'm gonna cruise
the entire faculty that we can eat
although we've discussed how there's
discrimination in Harry Potter it's
different to the blatant separation we
see at sage Academy muggle-born witches
and wizards aren't forbidden to do magic
or placed in a separate area at Hogwarts
however the UDM kids are treated totally
different to the other pupils in
upside-down magic they aren't allowed to
study magic the head teacher says they
have to stay away from the main school
building and it's this different
treatment that seems to form the basis
of the plot in the DC om
why would someone draw a children's book
although there are a few tweaks here and
there the Harry Potter movie is two
stayed true to the books
it looks like Disney's upside-down magic
movie departs from the source material
in a major way the DC om has introduced
a whole new character in the shape of
Nora's best friend Rena in the books
Nora's best friend is called Elliot and
he's an upside down flare that means he
freezes things instead of heating them
her other best friend is called pepper
but in the movie we get Rina who
certainly isn't performing upside down
magic
it looks like Riina's going to play a
major part in the plot JK Rowling would
not have stood for that nice big smile
Harry together you and I rate the front
page the main character in Harry Potter
is of course Harry Potter and a lot of
the main characters are male Ron
Dumbledore Hagrid Voldemort Rico you get
the idea but an upside-down magic the
main character is nori and many of the
leads are female including her best
friend Rina plus the head teacher of
sage Academy she's played by Vicki Lewis
and interestingly she's called
headmaster night slinger this focus on
female leads is an important difference
between the two magical worlds and we're
really pleased about it do you think
upside-down magic has copied too much
from Harry Potter or do you think it's
going to bring a fun new angle to
magical school set movies are you
excited for the DC om to hit our screens
on July 31st sound off in the comments
and be sure to hit that subscribe button
for more videos like this one thanks for
watching